If people in your town suddenly started
dying, horrible deaths, what would you do?
Everyone you love is getting murdered
by a mysterious plague
and the truth behind what is causing
it is more terrifying
than anyone can imagine.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do, and how to beat
the mysterious plague in Shiki.
This doctor here has no idea
that everyone he loves is about to die.
Toshio
Here is the town of Sotoba's Best Doctor
and who has just been tasked
with inspecting
a recent crime scene
on the outskirts of town.
This woman who died of natural causes
along with her husband and their neighbor
next door, who are both mutilated as hell
However, something is off
because Toshio can tell
that the wife of this couple died
several days after the husband
and their neighbor, which, if that's true,
means that this lady was living
with a mutilated corpse
for a whole week before she died herself
without telling anyone about it.
The police think it's just wild dogs,
but Toshio knows that this horror show
wasn't caused by wild dogs.
And he's right because later
he gets a call from a house nearby.
Someone from the village
has just gotten sick. Okay.
This peaceful little village
has already faced
what I would describe
to be a horrifying situation.
And the fact that this happened in a small
village makes this even worse.
Because being in a small town
means that anyone nearby could be next.
Now, the wild dog theory
is highly unlikely,
but even if it were true,
all it would take for them
to confirm this theory would be to see
if any of the entrance doors were open
and if there were any paw prints
or marks left within the house
or any dog hairs or urine from dogs.
I doubt any wild
dog would be able to open a door properly
without leaving some scratch marks,
nor be able to have wiped their paws
perfectly before entering the house.
I mean, I guess anything is possible,
but I highly doubt this theory is worth
following up on.
And another reason
why Death by Wild Dogs is super
unlikely is because, unlike Dom's hometown
of Thailand, Japan having stray dogs
just in
general is a highly rare occurrence due
to Article six, clause nine of the rabies
prevention law in Japan,
which states that stray dogs
must be impounded and disposed of
within a set amount of time
if owner comes forward.
Making Japan's kill rate of their nations
cats and dogs to be over 200,000 a year.
But that's a story for another day.
Something this huge happening in
such a small village would put me on edge.
And the police taking this lightly.
This is going to cost them.
Toshio
then rushes over to the sick girl's house
where we see her laying there sleepy
and in a daze, and who the doc thinks has
a mild case of anemia.
And so he takes a blood sample
and tells her to get some rest.
However, later, pink haired
girl begins to have insane visions
of a creepy blond woman and passes out.
And things are about to get
a whole lot more sinister
because the next morning
Toshio gets a call and finds out
that the very same pink girl
he took a blood
sample from has mysteriously died.
And no one knows how.
Toshio then asks the family
if he can do an autopsy,
but they demand that he get the hell out
instead forcing the town's best qualified
to doctor to leave
even more clueless than he was before.
The next day, the village holds a wake
for pink haired girl and the whole town
shows up, including this big city kid,
to turn small village student Natsuno.
and this dude is so cold and calloused.
It's disgusting.
And I love it
because this week only makes him
want to get the hell out of this town
even more.
However, little does he realize that
he'll soon join this girl instead.
Later that day, at the only hospital
and Sotoba, Toshio finally receives
the results of pink haired
girl's blood test
and what he is about to discover
could not be more insane.
Toshio discovers that pink hair girl
didn't have what he thought,
which was microcytic
hyopchromic anemia a.k.a.
iron deficiency anemia,
the most common type of anemia out there,
but instead finds out that she had
normocytic normochromic anemia,
which is usually caused by bleeding.
However, Toshio says that when he examined
pink hair girl,
he didn't find any visible wounds
or internal bleeding, meaning he doesn't
know how her body shut down so quickly.
And since they couldn't do an autopsy
on her, he had no clue what went wrong.
The hospital suddenly
then gets a call from another family
that someone else in the village has died,
this time being an old man who appears
to have died from a summer cold
and anemia just like pink hair girl.
Okay. What did I say before?
If I was in the big city,
I wouldn't think twice
about a death or two, whatever it happens.
But the fact of that multiple people died
within the last week within this tiny town
makes me nervous as hell.
Now, a summer cold is simply a cold.
They people usually catch during,
but not limited to the summer
with the most common symptoms
from this being a runny nose
coughing, congestion, headaches, pressure
in the head,
or sinus, low energy and muscle ache.
Among other things.
It's basically a collection of symptoms
rather than a defined disease.
And it's normally a mild illness that
usually resolves itself within a few days.
Although complications from the initial
cold is when things can get serious,
and it's also
when the initial mild symptoms
can evolve into a serious illness,
such as developing
into a respiratory infection,
especially within people
who have already compromised
or weak immune systems.
Like the elderly.
This is why wouldn't it be as concerned
if the deaths piling up
so far have been old people ages
65 years and older?
But the fact that a young girl
has also kicked the bucket
makes me think that this is a huge cause
for concern.
And the main part about anemia
being present is simply a condition
that can develop in people
suffering from various flus and certain
other infections.
This means that the anemia itself
is not an uncommon thing
to develop from having the sniffles
and isn't a factor
that I'd be super concerned with yet,
because the usual
go to method for treating anemia
is to simply treat
the underlying disease present.
But because we don't know
exactly what is going on yet,
makes me think that this isn't
your average summer cold.
And again, a young girl just died
and seemingly overnight.
I think it's time, guys, to take this
a little bit more seriously and maybe
break out the Lysol and start spraying
everybody's face as soon as possible.
Totally shock to the core,
but he doesn't even have time
to pieces thoughts together
because just then another call comes in
about someone else having died overnight,
and this time Toshio heads out even more
cautious than he's ever been before.
He finds out that this old lady died
strangely overnight, right after feeling
sleepy and dazed the whole day before,
and that she didn't want this
crying old lady
to take her to the hospital.
This is the last straw for Toshio,
who now, after seeing over
seven people die
within the last half of a month,
thinks something seriously
strange and worrying
is going on around town,
causing him to later
meet up with his best friend
and junior monk
say sing along with an official
from the town hall
to report on the number of residents
who have died within this month.
But what's strange
is that the town official informs Toshio
that even more people have died from this
unknown plague than he initially thought.
But they didn't report it earlier because
the victims died in the neighboring town.
They weren't originally included
in this town. Officials death records.
Tokyo's heart thuds in his chest
as he realizes that this may be the start
of a terrifying epidemic, with victims
initially having very minor symptoms
that will soon kill within a few days,
which means they have to hurry.
But Toshio tries to keep everyone cool
and in check, and he tells them to not
tell anyone about this epidemic
as they still have no concrete proof
and without proof
they don't have anything.
And so Toshio and Seishin set out
to get to work with Toshio the next day,
getting back a new blood sample
from the latest victim in town.
This purple haired girl
with the same problem as all the rest.
Anemia, basically
all the things that leaves this
good doctor even more stumped than before.
Not realizing that the explanation
to all of this dates back centuries.
Okay, let's cool it on the scientific
mister smart guy terms for a sec.
Now it would take a list.
Site is simply a red blood cell
that is still developing.
Think of them like baby
blood cells not yet fully matured
and an increase in reticulocyte count rise
when there's a lot of blood loss
or in certain diseases
in which red blood cells are destroyed
prematurely, such as hemolytic
anemia and the rest of the stuff
that Toshio mentioned,
such as nucleated erythrocyte
and hyperplasia of a throw blast
are basically various conditions
that can happen within the body.
All as a result of a lack of red blood
cells.
This is what we know so far.
However, I would also consider the body's
response towards the sudden changes
in red blood cell count
that is why I would also look
into the possibility of hemorrhagic shock
happening within the victims.
And to top that off, the symptoms between
anemia and hemorrhagic shock are similar.
This means that what Toshio thinks
could be
anemia could be as a result
from hemorrhagic shock.
So if we go with this hypothesis,
if I was Toshio, I would begin
looking into any visible
injuries external or internal to confirm
if this is indeed what is going on.
Here's the thing with such a crazy
sickness like this, I would inspect each
and every nook
and cranny of the skin of the victims,
because all of this could be
from a simple insect bite,
which goes to show how important it is
that we examine any and all cuts
that could be on the body,
no matter how small or insignificant
they may appear.
All of a sudden
a couple
then bust through the hospital doors
with this sick check, looking even worse
than when the doctor saw her yesterday
and Toshio yells out
in anger and frustration.
It seems as though every patient waits
until they're on their deathbed
before even stepping foot in a hospital.
It's almost as if they're being instructed
to avoid the hospital.
And Toshio then notices for the first time
these insect bites on this girl's arm
right as the team of doctors
admit her into the hospital.
But Toshio isn't done with his questions.
As he then begins to pry heavily
into the boyfriend of the sick girl
asking him
if he's been in contact
with anyone who could have passed
on this summer cold to them.
And that's when the boyfriend mentions
that the only people
that they met up with
until now was with a new couple
who just recently moved
into a castle up on the hill,
a couple that could only be described
as having the coldest
look about them with pitch-black eyes
and wonderous mental skin.
Eternally beautiful.
But Toshio is all about the sick
and disregards
the boyfriend's creepy commentary
heading back in to check on the girl.
But it's hopeless as she dies
later on anyways, adding yet
another body to the town's death records
and the doctor himself.
Not one step closer
to figuring any of this out
later that night, though
Natsuno stops by his best friend's house.
Toro,
who later goes to a coffee vending machine
and meets the strangest pale
skin male around their age.
This blue haired.
The guy who mentions that he also just
moved into the house on the hill
and who gets invited by Toro
to come chill at his house
some time for a video game night
and blue haired guy graciously accepts,
mentioning that he'll bring another friend
to join them in on the fun soon.
That same night,
Natsuno dreams of the very first victim
who he found out about pink haired girl
as she appears in the distance,
glaring back at our boy with blood
red eyes closing in with a smirk
that could kill until he suddenly wakes up
in the dead of night to an empty room.
The days pass as this mysterious plague
sweeps through the town, raiding
even the town's finest of their lives.
And the residents mentioned
that the families of those deceased
have begun moving away
the same night of the victim's deaths.
No funeral, no goodbyes, no nothing.
Leaving the rest of the town
more stumped than ever as to
what the hell is happening
and it keeps getting worse
because on one fateful day,
after receiving the blood sample of yet
another recently deceased a victim, Toshio
takes it upon himself to finally alert
the staff on what he thinks is going on
as his ingenious mind
finally connects the dots.
Or so he thinks with the 19 dead so far,
they're running out of time, and Toshio
thinks that this is truly an epidemic,
but not one
that's ever been documented before.
But before they can ask the town officials
or even the government for help,
they need to gather the data,
starting with their only lead
the condition of normal, sick,
normal chronic anemia.
That same night, the sleepy town of Sotoba
then braces itself for yet
another promising night of death
as Natsuno stays over at Tooru's house,
only to toss and turn late at night
with a gloomy feeling
of someone watching over him, seeing none
other than pink haired girl yet again
as she glides throughout the house
and towards the boy's room coming for her
prey until Natsuno finally wakes up
and he glares around only to see
his best friend safe and sound.
Except he looks awfully pale and almost
as if he just woke up from the dead.
But that's just a coincidence.
Natsuno thinks Tokyo's best friend,
Seishin,
finds out from some more neighbors
that a lot of people have begun
to leave the town,
only to mysteriously die later,
as if they knew their time was up
and they left knowing
that they would never return alive.
And the news only gets worse
for our simple townsfolk.
Because at school that day, Natsuno
suddenly notices that Toru is in there
and hears from a girl
that he's at home
playing a new video game that he got
but not to know, doesn't trust her
and he head straight
for his best friend's house.
Right as he arrives
he sees his beloved bro Tooru
just as he left him last tucked in
with a resting face paler
than a living corpse.
Except this time
he's more corpse than living.
Nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope, nope.
Something is definitely going on. And
it ain't no simple case of blood disorder.
We're seeing freaking ghost right now.
And now our best friend is dead.
Now, this could have been a simple case
of sleep paralysis,
which can happen
when your brain begins to wake up,
but your body is still in sleep mode,
resulting in you being awake
but paralyzed for a few moments
until your body snaps out of it.
And with sleep paralysis,
it can be very common to hallucinate
scary people or creatures
near your bed, particularly
if you happen to be conscious during the
rapid eye movement or REM cycle of sleep.
This is what I would have initially blamed
seeing pink haired girl early on.
However, now, with our friend dying
literally the morning after we saw her.
This makes me think that this is way
too much of a coincidence.
If I was nuts.
No, I take matters into my own dang
hands and visit
the only place that could provide us
with answers the clinic.
And because this is in no proper
giant hospital,
this makes me think that the protocols
and security measures in diverging
sensitive information to people
wouldn't be as strict
as if we were in a hospital in a big city.
So I think we have a very good chance
of simply walking in
and finding the town's superstar doctor
Toshio himself, because he's likely
the only one who will be able to separate
the town's speculation from facts.
And the fact that we essentially predicted
our friend's death can mean a few things
and may or may not have to do
with quantum entanglement.
Hear me out now
Like Albert Einstein once said Quantum
entanglement is basically the science
of spooky shit happening at a distance,
and this could explain what we saw.
Like someone who predicted their best
friend's death right before it happened.
Spooky occurrences like this
have actually been linked
to quantum biology,
which is basically the science
of studying shit
that doesn't follow
the normal laws of physics.
In short, the science behind
how Natsuno saw his best friend die before
his time could have either been dumb luck
or a phenomenon rooted in actual science.
Somehow
or confirmed to us that we actually did
see pink haired girl back from the dead,
and that she is actually somehow
responsible for our best friend's death.
A wave of dread suddenly spills over,
Natsuno, as his world suddenly plunges
into a darkness
that he never thought possible.
Because this time
he believes with his entire
being that pink her girl is behind this
and he's going to find out
how the next day then comes
revolving back
as if it were the day before.
With another patient's dead
and more families mourning,
Toshio sits deep and thought refusing
to give in to the worst plague
of his career, right as he goes through
the usual examination routine, noticing
another insect by the arm of the deceased
and he collects another blood sample.
Toshio then later meets up with Seishin
to update him on his investigation
into the villagers of the town.
And Seishin mentions
that he's coming across some strange
findings, noting that
more and more people have begun
leaving town only to die a few days later,
thinking it
to be connected to the epidemic somehow.
But Toshio has heard enough of this
and tells him to shut his eyed face up
thinking his efforts
to do nothing with the epidemic,
and that he's wasted
all of his time for nothing.
And he retreats back into what is might
well be his clinic of corpses
and the corpse fest continues
in the form of film flattery
as Natsuno began spending his nights
researching the monsters of Hollywood,
hoping to find some insight into
just what kind of monster Pink haired
girl is or he believes is just as then
this kid comments on the zombie film
that Natsuno is watching and mentions
that it reminds him of the town legend
that he grew up with within this village.
The Legend of the Okiyagari,
also known as The Dead, who rise at night
and they would come back from beyond the
grave to punish children who misbehaved.
Or so the folklore says
and this strikes a chord with Natsuno,
because thanks to this guy,
he now knows that he's onto something.
Okay, okay.
While it might seem silly,
this could actually be our best bet
in gaining some insight into
what the hell is going on.
Because from the looks of things,
they really don't have the internet,
which means films is
our only means of trying to find examples
of what we're experiencing in real life.
The brain naturally likes
to find patterns in things,
so let's use it to our advantage
in this case,
because our town's doctors can't
figure out what the hell is going on.
So this is the next best thing
because such things like the undead
and ghouls
initially came from such places
like folklore.
Back before we could explain everything
with science to suggest why certain things
the way they were.
In fact, a very popular theory
of how zombies were made
comes from a scientist
by the name of David Wade,
who claim to have found a neurotoxin
in a powder used by magicians
in which they would make the victim fall
into a deep coma appearing to be dead.
And within a few days after the funeral,
the victim would
then be awoken by the magician again,
giving off the illusion
that they were a zombie.
So while a lot of what of the films
say about zombies
and the undead may be complete bullshit,
there might be a few hints of truth hidden
within that
we could use to better understand
what's going on.
Because remember,
we saw a pink haired girl
appear in our dreams
as some freaky zombie thing,
and then our best friend died
within the next day.
And also, at this moment, modern day
science can't really explain the shit
that is going on right now.
However, the fact remains
that there are thousands of films
and books
written on the subject of scary ass
paranormal shit,
which means we could potentially find
certain instances
within folklore to explain
what the hell is going on.
And remember, no internet.
So I would utilize the town's a library
for any more books
based on mythological lore,
anything we could use to help
explain what we saw the next day.
Natsuno confronts Toshio about pink
hair girl since Toshio was the one
who examined her corpse
and wrote of her death certificate,
but Toshio assures him
that she was definitely dead
when he examined her
with rigor mortis already setting in.
By the time he arrived,
he reassures, worried to not to know
that there's no way she could be alive
unless she took a page
right out of Hollywood
and came back as a zombie or a vampire.
This sends a wave of realization down
not to no spine,
and he heads off abruptly, leaving
Toshio confused as all hell
and makes him suspect that this is in fact
not an epidemic after all.
Elsewhere, two curious kids
stake out the castle on the hill,
and this kid sure as shit believes
that he saw one of the recently deceased
entered the castle.
And these poor kids are completely unaware
that blue haired guy
is staking them out from the shadows
and watching.
Then later as they walk back,
not to know, spots them and mentions
that they were just being watched
until he realizes that just like him,
they think something is going on
in that mansion too.
And the two kids hear that nods.
No suspects everything that's gone
wrong, including the deaths,
pink haired girl and even blue haired
guy are all due to the fact
that they are Okiyagari undead
who have risen from the grave.
And that's why Natsuno
has been seeing pink haired
girl in his dreams because she's come back
straight from the dead.
This solidifies these kids belief
that the dead person they saw entered
the castle is also an Okiyagari
However, not to know
says that they need to know for sure,
which is why he suggests
that they dig up a pink hair
girl's grave in order to find out clearly
not caring about any decency for the dead
Later, back at the clinic, Toshio invites
Satan over to discuss his findings,
findings
that will change the course of history
for the worst.
Satan interrupts
Toshio to tell him that recently
all the death certificates from the town
have gone missing,
meaning now
they don't have the proper paperwork
to officially prove
how many people they lost in the village,
meaning they won't be able
to call the government for help.
But Toshio couldn't care less and mentions
that what's going on isn't an epidemic
after all,
that all of these deaths are happening
because of the Okiyagari or more
specifically in Layman terms, vampires.
This casts a fainting spell over
Satan, who begs Toshio to tell him
that he's joking but tough shit he isn't.
Because it's one thing to die
from hemorrhagic shock,
but what disease would cause people to
quit their job and physically move away?
And Toshio mentions that these creatures
are probably using hypnosis
on their victims as they feed on them.
Ordering them to move towns away
right before their death.
And in this way they've managed to prevent
the town's death rate from ever going up,
at least officially.
Okay, so they were dead
wrong about them being zombies,
which actually makes a whole
lot more sense.
However, one thing that doesn't make sense
is how some of them are able
to withstand sunlight like blue hair guy,
because he clearly was watching
the two kids in broad daylight.
But let's put a pin in this one for now,
because at this point,
all signs are pointing to the worst
and most insane scenario
that vampires are Okiyagari,
are the cause behind all of this,
which means we need to be sure
that Satan actually believes us.
Because I'll admit this scary fact
can be a tough pill to swallow.
And from here on out,
we can't have anyone on our side
who has any doubts about this.
Now that we know what's going
on, it's pretty darn likely
they will eventually come face to face
with the Okiyagari soon enough, especially
once they know that we know about them.
If I'm Toshio, I'd start by revealing
that these bug bites aren't
bug bites at all, but actually bite marks
from Okiyagari on all of the past victims
and actually find some way
to prove it to them
that these biomarkers were made by God
and not by something from nature.
And because of all of this, Tokyo
now has a plan, starting with the latest
soon to be a victim who Toshio invites
to stay at his clinic overnight,
knowing that whatever monster is sucking
her dry will be forced to pay them a visit
tonight. Elsewhere,
the gang visits the burial site.
Ultimately discovering that
the coffin, which they thought was filled
for so long, is in fact empty.
Then suddenly a cold pair of hands up
took this little girl and plunged deep
within the enshrouded forest
and are about to bite into her flesh
before she reveals a holy token
right in front of this monster's face.
Stopping him
just long enough before not to know,
swings a shovel right into his face,
knocking him out.
They quickly feel his pulse and realize
that this beast doesn't have one,
making him officially part of the undead.
Shocking the gang to the core
not to know quickly,
then says to bury his corpse
to see if he rises up again tomorrow.
And so they begin shoveling,
working through the dead of night
until this guy's cold, limp
body gets buried six feet deep.
Then after a sleepless night,
they returned the next day.
And what they discover only confirms
what they dare
hope wasn't true, that the corpse
that they buried at last night.
Just a like pink haired
girl rose up a back from the grave,
solidifying their suspicions that their
small town of Sotoba has been invaded by.
Oh, God,
this little kid
suddenly has had enough of this
freak show and demands that they charge
right up to the mansion on the hill
and attack
whatever monsters lay dormant within.
But Natsuno stops him dead in his tracks
because the cold, hard truth is that
they don't know what they're up against,
whether they're
in fact a zombie or a vampire,
because that blue haired kid was spotted
checking them out in broad daylight,
meaning that whatever they do,
they need to figure out
what they're up against first.
How many of them are there, and most
importantly, how to kill them not to know.
Then suggests
that they test out the stake
to the heart theory
for the next person that inevitably
will fall victim to this plague
because they need to figure out
how to stop these monsters soon okay.
This is insane.
We finally know what the hell is going
on. Sorta.
Except now it's even more terrifying
since we don't know anything else.
Natsuno is in a pretty tight spot
right now.
We don't know
exactly what these creatures are.
They are similar to vampires,
but they're not exactly like vampires.
How do we kill them?
Because all we got so far is to rely on
what the movies, TV shows, and books
have told us.
But does any of that shit
actually work on them?
Until we find that out,
I want to stake my life on coming
face to face with any one of them.
However, what not to said is a solid place
to start a stake through the heart.
And I'd also maybe
add severing the human head
and setting them on fire
as a means of taking them out.
Because whilst sunlight
and maybe a cross to their face
might not harm them, relying on attacking
or ideally obliterating
the two most important organs, the brain
and the heart will probably be a good way
to kill them without necessarily
knowing that it'll work beforehand.
The heart sends blood throughout the body
and to the brain,
and it also provides the body
with oxygen and various nutrients.
The brain is basically a one stop shop
for everything
that the body needs in order to function
it is the command center
for the nervous system
and vampire or Okiyagari or not,
there's little possibility
that they'll be able to function
without a head attached to their body.
I don't care how scary they are.
There are some things they can't break.
The laws of science people into living
without your head is probably one of them.
Until we know more,
I'd stick to impaling the heart,
severing the head,
or sending them on fire
during the cover of daylight,
at least for now,
because there's almost no shot
that one of those methods won't work
that same night.
Toshio and Seishin set up
for what will likely
be the most horrifying
night of their life so far,
and they take watch over the latest plague
victim
as she lays resting in the hospital room.
Because despite everything, Toshio knows
that these monsters have taken their time
killing their prey
so far since all the victims up
until now have taken four days to die.
Meaning that due to the sheer
amount of blood within the human body,
these horrifying creatures on average
probably take days
to completely drain their victims dry.
Toshio
also thinks that these undead creatures
inject
some sort of toxin into their victims
to prevent them from crying out for help
during the whole process,
much like some insect species that inject
a narcotic substance into their prey
to let them feed in peace,
whatever the case may
be, Toshio is sure that these demons
will strike again tonight.
Later, Toshio and Seishin await
outside the room of their patient,
just as they hear the old lady
call out her whereabouts
making Toshio suspect
that the undead are nearby.
And he's right
because he goes up to the only other point
of entry and pulls down the blinders,
revealing the most horrifying thing
a pair of blood red eyes
attached to a floating corpse.
And this Edward Cullen wannabe floats
back down to the floor
right before Toshio angrily
blasts open the window and declares
that he'll knock their teeth in
if they set one foot inside that hospital.
And this, thank God a non shiny
bloodsucker keeps her distance and Toshio
safely secures this frail old lady soul
from damnation for another night.
Okay, there's little reason
to think that vampires are okay.
Galleries last night
didn't enter because he didn't feel like
he didn't enter because he couldn't.
And this is one advantage
that we now know for sure
because right now we're kind of screwed
because it won't be long
before that one
vampire brings reinforcements
which means we got to go balls to the wall
from here on out.
And this means letting the others
know finally about
what the hell is really going on.
Keeping it secret isn't helping.
Anyway,
I would use the advantage of daylight
to inform all the staff
that we're planning a very important
meeting late at night,
and I would purposely stash
mainly weapons of all types in
and around the floor
of where the old lady is being held.
Before night comes around.
Then, using the cover of a meeting,
I'd be able to have all the nurses
and doctors from the clinic gather
within the same room as the old lady
while we wait for the vampires.
I mean, okay.
Gari to come back
because informing our colleagues
that this plague
is actually the result of Okay,
gory will be a tough sell
and we're better off showing them.
Now, of course, by the time
the ocher gallery do arrive,
they'll be unprepared as hell and will be
expecting such a huge conflict to arise.
Which, by the way, is the exact reason
why I'd stash as many weapons
around the room and floor of our patient.
Because when these Oak Gallery
inevitably come back and our colleagues
finally see firsthand
how horrifying these things are,
I'm pretty sure then they won't mind
grabbing a gun and helping out.
And besides,
even if they decide to not help me,
they'd at least make for
some really sweet meat shields for me
and Seishin to try and take some pot shots
at nature's most horrifying creation.
The next day arrives
as they come to discover their old lady
patient is actually recovering,
meaning that they've just discovered
how to reverse the sickness
Toshio and Seishin
and then take five to bless
the Japanese gods for their luck so far
before they begin preparing themselves
for another night of horror.
Something is starting to suspect
that if the legends and movies are right,
then that Okiyagari didn't enter
last night because it needed permission
to enter and enter.
They won't, because then our duel heroes
begin preparing for another night of chaos
as darkness
finally sets again over the hospital.
And just then the power goes out,
forcing these two
to rush back into the old ladies room,
only to see through the hospital window
that this place is now
surrounded by Okiyagari
and Toshio doesn't even have a chance
to prepare himself for battle
because blue haired guy
comes up from behind and knocks him out.
Shocking are two heroes into wondering who
and what these creatures
really are, including blue haired guy.
The doc then stumbles to his feet
and heads to the window
and he's forced to witness
his beloved patient
get brutally slaughtered
by the rest of the Okiyagari.
Horde,
killing her before evading into the night,
instilling more rage
into Tokyo than ever before.
And he prepares to right himself
ceasing and anyone else willing to fight
these terrifying monsters head on.
Setting the stage for the first official.
Okay, gory war
in the history of the modern day world.
And you're going to help us
find the Okiyagari.
Don't forget to like come and subscribe
and check out a tribute playlist below.